my name is Kieran Kumar I'm from the SLO
fellows 2012 program it was Amy G I
graduated from the slone fellas program
in
2010 my name is Sam aleska I was a SLO
fellow back in'
09 I'm the vice president general
manager of locked Martin's commercial
engine
Solutions loed Martin identified me to
send to Sloan which was a great
opportunity lucky Martin is known for
their
technology we in the business of
creating economic growth for Singapore
and ultimately creating good jobs for
singaporeans I was lucky to have my
organization the economic development
Board of Singapore sponsor my year at
MIT s Ram has been involved with Islam
fell programs for I would say about over
a decade
now I head Upstream research the
geosciences geoh physics
geology the stone fellow program allows
me to ask much better questions I think
it gives me different Frameworks when I
look at an organization
I think I develop uh much more robust
options that I can explore before
committing to any project I look at
alignment of issues I no longer look at
the specific sphere that I'm working in
I think I look at uh the impact of
different proponents within
aramco Sloan really um came at the right
time to round out my abilities it
enhanced what I think um I needed it
gave me the confidence it gave locky the
confidence that I was going to be
exposed to um anywhere from the
financials to the Strategic um
Frameworks of how to think about a
business Sloan Amplified my skill sets
that I had gotten through Consulting and
the staff function but better prepared
me to be a line
leader I was a young manager out in New
York managing a team of Center directors
who manage our operations in Americas so
really the transition for me was to move
from a manager
to coming back and becoming a leader and
MIT really helped in that transformation
I think what I brought back from MIT is
the ability to think out of the box uh
to challenge the status quo that's of
tremendous value because
the the business that we're in we are
developing many Industries and so the
other participants in the programs come
from wide variety of Industries
functions and experiences in different
geographies some of them could be
potential partners for
us lock Martin's growing internationally
and my particular line of business is a
global market if you look at Singapore
we're a small country we move from third
world to First in one generation the
question is where do we go from here and
that requires different perspectives we
operate in the global context if you
look at Economic Development and that
Global Perspective that came from MIT
helps me to look at things from a
different
frame
we had 102 classmates from all over the
world in diverse Industries having
experiences in government in business in
technology in entrepreneurship and that
experience and those discussions I think
also colored my thoughts and experiences
as it relates to what I'm doing here
today the clear Focus for that program
was leadership you've got to adjust your
St style for each group that you're with
while still staying true to the mission
true to the business and true to
yourself morning guys it really made you
examine very critically your leadership
style your own personal motivations in
leadership how your own lens clouds or
um Slants away you lead your team and I
was impacted by how I saw my peers I
think about these things and I and I
took away a little bit from
everyone our employees who have attended
the MIT Stone fell program that grown
and mature that really comes from the
deepening of knowledge and insights that
they gain from the program broaden
perspectives and tighten awareness of
themselves of what they can do and how
to be more effective as a leader the
culture of MIT actually resonates with
me a lot the culture of innovation the
culture of humility the culture of
working hard and the culture of making
sure that whatever you do impact Society
in a positive
way hello I'm Steven Saka director of
the MIT SLO fellows program and alumnus
of the program class of 1990 as you
consider your management development
needs please feel free to contact us to
discuss how the program can benefit you
and your organization thank
you